y nos preguntan cuál es el valor crítico
te estrella o te asterisco para
construir un intervalo de confianza del
98 por ciento para la media de una
muestra de tamaño n igual a 15
observaciones recordemos de qué se trata
esto tenemos una población con un cierto
parámetro para este ejemplo digamos que
tenemos una media poblacional no
conocemos lo que es esto por lo que
tomamos una muestra en este caso
tomaremos una muestra de 15 así que n es
igual a 15 y para esta muestra podemos
calcular una media muestral pero también
queremos construir un intervalo de
confianza del 98% alrededor de esa media
muestral para lo cual tomaremos esa
media muestral más menos cierto margen
de error ya hemos mencionado en otros
vídeos necesitamos en este caso usar una
distribución t ya que no queremos
subestimar el margen de error esto va a
hacerte estrella por la desviación
estándar de la muestra dividida entre la
raíz cuadrada del tamaño de la muestra
lo cual en este caso es 15 raíz cuadrada
de n lo que nos preguntan
específicamente es cuál es el valor
crítico adecuado
es la t estrella que debemos usar en
este caso en particular así que estamos
por revisar lo que diríamos es una tabla
t en lugar de una tabla zeta sin embargo
hay una cuestión que tenemos que tomar
en cuenta hay una variable extra por
considerar cuando buscamos un valor
crítico específico en una tabla t la
cual corresponde al concepto de grados
de libertad en ocasiones abreviado por g
l no voy a profundizar en el concepto de
grados de libertad el cual no es tan
simple pero está relacionado con que se
tiene una distribución t diferente
dependiendo del tamaño de la muestra
dependiendo de los grados de libertad
los grados de libertad están dados por
el tamaño de la muestra menos 1 en este
caso nuestros grados de libertad van a
ser 15 menos 1 por lo tanto los grados
de libertad van a ser iguales a 14 esta
no es la primera vez que vemos esto
comentamos acerca de los grados de
libertad cuando hablamos por primera vez
de la desviación estándar muestral y
como resulta que es un estimador in
sesgado de la desviación estándar
poblacional en futuros vídeos
profundizaremos sobre este concepto de
grados de libertad para fines de este
ejemplo necesita
saber que cuando buscamos en una
distribución t para un número específico
de grados de libertad los grados de
libertad dependen del tamaño de la
muestra y van a estar dados por el
tamaño de la muestra menos 1 cuando
queremos encontrar un intervalo de
confianza para la media veamos entonces
la tabla t queremos un intervalo de
confianza de 98 por ciento y tenemos 14
grados de libertad sacamos nuestra tabla
t de hecho la copié y la pegué ajustando
la para que la veamos completa lo que es
muy útil de esta tabla es que de hecho
nos da los niveles de confianza aquí
abajo como queremos un nivel de
confianza del 98 por ciento vamos a usar
esta columna usaremos esta columna que
tenemos aquí otra manera de considerar
el nivel de confianza del 98% es si
tenemos un nivel de confianza del 98 por
ciento eso quiere decir que necesitamos
que las colas a ambos lados sean de 1%
así que si estamos buscando el valor en
la distribución que que incluye todo
menos el 1% superior vamos a buscar el
valor que corresponde a una cola de 0.01
que corresponde a esto va a ser la
probabilidad que nos deja esta cola
derecha de cualquier manera estamos en
esta columna de aquí requerimos un nivel
de conciencia del 98 por ciento ya
sabemos que tenemos 14 grados de
libertad así que este es el renglón
correspondiente y aquí lo tenemos
este es nuestro valor crítico 2.624
regresamos a la pregunta aquí lo ponemos
2.624 es la respuesta nos vemos en otro
vídeo